the Kremlin is rejecting British
allegations that Russia is behind the
nerve agent attack on a former spy and
his daughter in England britain's
Foreign Secretary calls it a signature
act by the Russian state meanwhile
Russian President Vladimir Putin
traveled to Crimea for a massive
campaign rally days before his country's
election Russia took over Crimea from
Ukraine four years ago and faced
international condemnation Elizabeth
Palmer was at the rally and joins us
from the Crimea port city of Sevastopol
Elizabeth good morning good morning with
only three days to go now before the
presidential elections the Kremlin is
pushing back hard against Britain's
accusations here in Russia president
Putin's supporters are solidly behind
their government even though they know
it means international condemnation it's
a deeply symbolic gesture he told the
crowd has come home to Russia but I see
he's referring to 2014 when Russian
soldiers seized the territory from
Ukraine it was a land grab most Russians
approved of the rest of the world
declared it illegal on his tour here
Putin also visited the bridge Russia is
building from its mainland to Crimea
literally cementing its claim the
message to the US and the West
Putin is never giving it back to a
biased Russia baiting world goes down
well here and Putin knows it he also
knows he's gonna win on Sunday which may
be the reason he gave the home crowd a
rare glimpse of his warm and fuzzy side
I feel good wouldn't lie you might hug
outwardly though there's no warm and
fuzzy the Kremlin is sticking to its
tough line threaten us all you like we
did not poison Sergey scribble Gail
right Elizabeth Palmer reporting from
Crimea thank you